you made a living as an actor outside of
LA for a good 12 years correct so for
the last several years now you've made a
living from acting in LA what's your
opinion on where and unestablished actor
should live if he or she wants to make a
living as an actor if you want to make a
living as an actor live centrally
Hollywood is great because it's easy to
get to everywhere Studio City also okay
but look at the map and try to put right
in the center and don't be as concerned
with going to the beach or where the
clubs are I mean maybe this is easier
for me to say because I'm in the middle
age but I'm not here to play I'm here to
work so where I chose to live was
determined by talking to people in the
business and asking them where am I most
likely to have to drive to and I want to
be right in the center of that for God's
sake don't get far out on the freeway
and think I'm going to drive into LA for
every audition and shoot because you're
not you're gonna get a callback that
says hey can you be here in two hours
and you look at traffic and you're like
no I can't so you have to plan for that
so it's a full-time job every single day
it's a full-time job
speaking of clubs and having fun I know
that networking is a great part of the
business and a lot of its who you know
but what about people that want to be
part of the group and they're always
hanging out and they want to talk about
films but maybe nothing gets done and
they don't want to rock the group
dynamics do you think you have to almost
be a lone wolf in some sense I do think
you have to be a lone wolf because
you're moving within several groups of
people
I have small independent producers now I
have some larger producers that I deal
with
I have directors that I work for for 50
bucks when I first came here I have
larger directors now who are doing
million-dollar films and then all of
these circles are rarely intersect and
you have to be able to to go and speak
to each one of them as needed I I don't
think it's a good idea to hang with a
certain group all the time and you do
have to be social you do have to be able
to network but I do believe that being a
lone wolf is an advantage to an actor
because you aren't like a wolf right I
mean you're always you're always on the
prowl you're always on the hunt you're
always looking for the relationship that
will help you and I know that sound
cynical but that's the business and
that's any business you spend your time
on the relationships that are likely to
benefit you and that person it's
symbiotic well you see it you go into a
restaurant everyone turns around to see
who's walking in yes and then they look
do I know that person can I go up to
their table can I pitch them something
so I think everybody does it on any
level that's right they're starting out
and whether they're an established
studio person I think you're always
looking for that next thing but no one
can hook you up and this is something
people should tell actors who are coming
to LA because I've now just started to
reach the level where I will have a
younger actor occasionally say hey you
know could you hook me up with so-and-so
no no I can't it took me four years to
hook myself up baby you know you hook
yourself up was it was the great old
story of Betty Davis and I don't know
where she was but some young actress
asked her you know how would you advise
me to get into studio films in Hollywood
and she said take fountain Avenue it's
quicker than Hollywood and that's her
advice and she was saying I got mine you
get yours yes you'll help other people
out but no one can I don't think even a
really really established actor can call
a director and say hey I think you
should put bill on my film because I
like him people don't like that they
don't like being forced a lot of people
because I've heard from people that I
know that they thought friends or
someone would help them get that extra
leg up and they were disappointed once
it didn't happen oh yes I do think a lot
of people and I think it's a big lie and
people who come here need to know I just
spoke to someone yesterday he was like
oh I got a buddy who's on a TV show
she's gonna let me sleep on his couch
and he said he'd hook me up I got that
message on Facebook and I wrote back
good luck man I hope everything works
out but I'm thinking he ain't gonna hook
you up you can't hook anybody up here
it's every person for themselves it's a
very mercenary bit do I sound cold no no
I think you sound like a realist --mess
this is not play this is not glamour you
put on the makeup you put on the dress
you put on the suit you go do the red
carpet but you do it because it's a part
of business the ordinary public for whom
this video is not intended does not need
to know any of this it spoils their
illusion just as much as if the camera
tilted up on a set and suddenly you
could see the ceiling this is not for
them but if you're an actor and you're
moving to LA this is for you this is a
very very difficult business
it's a of a business and it'll eat
you alive and you talked about earlier
coming to LA a little bit older
sometimes people come out of college or
maybe they skips college and they come
here and do you think maybe that was
even more helpful that you came as a
more mature person because you weren't
swayed by hanging out with the group and
wanting to be with the cool crowd having
drinks on Friday night I was weird even
when I was 20 so I probably would have
been alone them but yeah it's been good
because you know I was a theatre guy for
14 years and I did a lot of traveling on
back roads and loading in loading out
and cleaning bathrooms and putting on
Mark Twain wigs and basements that only
had cold water and scrubbing it off and
you know you learn doing that it gives
you confidence I think by the time you
reach middle age you do have confidence
that that it's gonna be alright you know
that you can do pretty much anything or
try anything the bad side have come in
at middle age of course is that it's a
very youth based culture and you have to
find a niche which is why I've you know
been lucky to have this face and be able
to be the scary guy the disturbing guy
the weird guy because otherwise I'd just
be a middle-aged actor with that skin
and I'd have been back east in six
months if I wasn't frightening
you